hey everybody its Jessie and today we're
gonna do some stuff with forms and react
so if if any of you have built something
with react where you needed to handle
form data especially if you had to
handle file uploads let me know what you
like to use if you know if there's some
some package or something that makes it
easy that you think is awesome let me
know and I'll check it out and I might
use it otherwise I think I'll just start
out by making some controlled components
some controlled inputs and and we'll
just go from there and see how much we
can get done I have on the screen the
URL for our server our end rocks server
so you can check out everything that
we're doing you know live and I'm gonna
paste that into the live chat all right
I see some people were saying hi in the
live chat
hey everyone hey thanks for watching
okay and as usual we have the the
secondary stream going on on on
Instagram as well the links in the
description so while we're waiting wait
for everybody to join let me just
briefly thank those of you who submitted
pull requests so we had four or three
three three for us yeah we had three
pull requests since yesterday stream so
thank you to Kevin and Sebastian for the
pull request I merge these in this one
eye closed just because
Sebastian had already done the same
thing in this pull request but this one
this pull request had some other stuff
that I wanted to merge so since I was
gonna merge this anyway I just closed
this one otherwise there would have been
merged conflicts because the same lines
were being changed in the files so but
we have basically some additional
testing and then now if you do clone the
the repo and you try to commit something
the tests will run on commit so it'll be
a little little extra in your in your
console you'll see that the test run and
when we can I'm assuming that at some
point during today's stream will commit
something so you'll be able to see what
that looks like in the terminal so that
was awesome thanks Kevin
and Sebastian did it he did a few things
so he moved move the components into the
proper folder a little bit of
organization and made sure that it when
we're where we were using that component
the the path changed to reflect the new
location and then also we have this you
could you could see it if you're
checking out the N drop link but I'll
bring it over I kept on my other screen
yeah let me bring this over so the
upload button so we we ended the string
yesterday talking about this file upload
so what Sebastian did was took all these
styles and some of the JavaScript for
the file upload actually it converted
the JavaScript that was being used by
materialized framework into something
that was better with react you know the
more of the react way of doing things
and got the file upload working so
it looks good it looks almost exactly
like what I had before which I'll I'll
bring that on the screen to to compare I
gotta open it again this it always loves
me out of the system that this is in I
always have to log back in but with the
exception of the color and possibly the
size you can see it looks pretty much
exactly the same the only thing that I
guess we don't have is this this text
which i think is not necessary maybe the
only reason I put that there was just to
let people know that they could upload
more than one file but that's implied by
the use of the plural files here as well
so I'm not even sure I'm gonna put that
in here so thank thank you for that
Sebastian and Kevin and you can see I've
added in the the proper labels for a lot
of these and down here actually this was
way more tricky than I thought it would
be so the default for checkbox is the
material UI is that you can click
anywhere on the label and it'll either
select that checkbox or unselected so I
tried to put a link in here and I did
put the link in so you can I was able to
pass in an element and I just wrapped
this in a span and then put the link in
but I couldn't click it every time I
tried to click the link it actually you
know made the checkbox become selected
and unselected so this it's a little bit
odd so the solution after I shot a few
things the best solution was there was
basically a div that was enclosing all
of this and I just
the div like I think 35 pixels wide so
now the div stops you can see where it
stops like right here so then that
allows this link to work so a little bit
of an odd thing but just thought I'd
bring that up and in case in case anyone
wondered if you looked at the code and
saw the weird stuff I was going with
this that's why I did it like that
all right so we have the form and I mean
with the exception of you know some
minor minor things of you know the
padding and things like that the names
for these this is pretty much what the
form is going to be also changed this a
bit but what I want to do is have this
form actually do something because right
now nothing happens you can hit the
submit button and nothing happens
so we need we need to do something so
let me let me explain what how I
envisioned this working and then you all
can let me know whether or not that's a
good idea or if you have a better idea
so what will happen basically is all
these will be controlled let me bring up
just so you all know in case you're not
familiar with the idea of controlled
input where did I have it I always have
too many windows open to have it here oh
I had it up here the whole time
okay so controlled components if you go
to just the the react Doc's Facebook
github io / react slash Docs and you go
to the forms page it talks about this so
you can read up more on it but basically
what we're gonna do is every time one of
these changes
so the value changes it's going to
update the state for that component and
then the value we get the value for that
component from state so what ends up
happening is that we don't change the
value directly I mean sitting from a
user's perspective it works the same way
but what's happening behind the scenes
is that we don't change the value
directly when you we type in here the on
change fires and then it changes the
state and then since the state has
changed it causes the render the
rerender and then the value you get the
value from state so everything kind of
flows
I guess differently normally it's just
like directly changing the value when
you type in there now why would we want
to do it like that
well one nice thing is it makes it easy
to do validation so I don't know that I
absolutely need a lot of validation for
this but it leaves us open to that if we
do it like this right away also all of
our values then are going to be in the
state and it's going to be really easy
to pull those values and do whatever we
need to with them so we're gonna do that
we're gonna grab the at some point when
the user click Submit
we're gonna need to get all those values
and what's probably gonna happen is
they're gonna get sent to our server j/s
which we may have to eject or create
react app so as you know we used create
react app to do this and if you notice
we don't have a server ojs file here so
we're probably going to need to eject it
unless anyone else has a better idea
we're going to need to eject that and
then we're going to
in our form data there and then handle
everything there server-side that way
you know we don't have to worry about
exposing any API keys on the client-side
which currently I am actually doing to
make this work where it is now and the
only reason I was comfortable doing that
is because it was behind a password so
no one could even see this page unless
they were able to log in and only
employees of the University could log in
so I was I was ok with that because
probably 99% of the employees would have
no idea even how to find the key and if
they found it they would wouldn't know
what it did for any of the api's that
we're gonna be using so now that it's
not gonna be beyond the password
definitely don't want to handle that
stuff client-side so I want to do
everything server-side and that's the
plan so having said all that what do you
think let me know in the live chat if
you're watching this later on let me
know in the comments if you're watching
it way later on then I guess don't worry
about because this project will probably
already be completed but if you do have
an opinion you can still let me know
I'll read it later on it just won't get
into this project maybe a future project
so hey to everyone joining me in an
Instagram I think okay it looks like I
recognized the names in the Instagram so
you all know what's going on I don't
have to tell you where to see the code
at all right so let me check the live
chat since I said a lot of stuff and I
want to hear what you all think
all right so Don Xavier says four forms
you can go with form Z react has some
validation and other goodies and if you
want material you I check out form Z
material you I okay cool I'm gonna check
that out
let me bring that up on my other screen
here I like that they already have
something with mature UI
all right some checking out the github
page now let me bring this over so we
had a suggestion you use form Z the form
Z mature UI
okay it seems pretty straightforward
it's not not a whole lot in the readme
if you see something to get home that
has a short read me it's either really
simple or there's there's just not a lot
of directions they come with it so it
could be really good or not really good
but this looks pretty straightforward
maybe we use that let me uh let me see
what else what else you all think
okay Sebastian Sebastian added something
that should be showing up okay so let
file value equals the state file input
okay so basically Sebastian is saying
here this is our service request form
component that what should happen the
file value should say select a file to
upload if there's nothing in state four
where's the file
input so yeah I'm not really sure why
that's not working
let me refresh it was do that
you refresh the page and see that's all
I'm gonna check what the state is in dev
tools it opened on the other screen
there but okay that's odd maybe so it's
showing an empty array for actually
notes yeah for file input it's showing
an empty array maybe I don't know maybe
since it actually exists even though
it's an empty array it's it's not
triggering the the war side of that but
that's cool since that's in there I can
make that work and then that'll just be
an easy way to have that text show up so
thanks thanks for pointing that out
Sebastian ok Roland says shouldn't the
planning guy to open in a new tab that
is a good idea so if you notice when I
click planning guide it didn't open a
new tab but you would except in a new
tab
especially actually I want to see if I
type stuff in I want to see if it saves
if I were to hit back no it actually
cleared it out yes a good call on that
definitely want this to open in a new
tab otherwise it would be super
frustrating for someone to fill all this
out get to the bottom say I'd like to
read the planning guide first and then
have it all taken away so I think on the
current version it doesn't take it away
so it doesn't clear the fields
so we'll have to see I was trying to
think of a way where I could make it
make everything stay there I mean the
really the simplest solution is to make
this open in a new tab so I will do that
let me add that so I finally get the
Trello board going a little bit so I can
I'll send a link to this I'll share it
and then put a link in the video if
hopefully I'll remember later on to do
it and then you all can check out this
Trello board as as I'm working with it
adding to it
and that should not take very long so
I'm going to put that down for a half of
a pomodoro cycle all right so good stuff
you all have great ideas for me already
it's just at the beginning of the stream
Andrew says hi Jesse just wanted to
thank you so much for sharing your work
as a beginner learning react this has
been so helpful to me oh well thanks for
saying that I'm glad that this is
helpful to you and I really appreciate
[Music]
you saying that and then whenever
anybody has some positive feedback for
me I appreciate that
I don't mind critical feedback either so
occasionally I get feedback that's not
so positive but there's always something
that that can be helpful even in a
negative feedback unless it's just
completely crazy and somebody's really
angry but usually there's something
something helpful but the positive stuff
keeps me going and it makes me really
look forward to these dreams and I'm
really happy that that I'm helping some
of you out I know you all are helping me
out I've learned so much from from you
since I've started streaming I think
this has been the fastest I've ever
learned maybe since I've heard you know
when you first start you fly through
HTML and CSS and think you're awesome
like and then you hit JavaScript and
they're like can't do anything once you
starts to do difficult things so aside
from that first early time of rapid
rapid learning this has been like
amazing because when you all submit code
to me I have to try to figure it out I
don't want to just pull it in without
understanding it so I've been learning
quite a lot
oh cool rollin said the the Instagram
stream is synced with this one that's
really cool I'm glad I never thought
about it until now but I guess it would
be really hard to watch if they were out
of sync it would it would be weird so
that's cool that it's it's all synced up
okay bill said that he used formzee
material you I and a react project
recently and liked how easy it was to
use awesome definitely think I might end
up using that
okay Sebastian said if I set the initial
state to null then this text should show
up so am i setting yeah here it is I'm
setting state there all right let's
check check that out yeah that works
okay cool so yeah I'll probably end up
changing the color which I was gonna
change the color these anyway all of
them so I'll just do it when I do that
but cool so now the text does appear
there and awesome cool thanks for that
Sebastian
sebastian what's up with the frowny face
emoji did I say something that made you
said I remember what I was saying
Philips hit the Instagram people will be
like question mark question mark yeah
I've had people pop in on Instagram
during the stream before and just type
like WTF and then leave they wonder why
I'm just here because all you see on the
instagrams stream is just me talking not
even looking at the stream most of the
time I'm looking at my screen and just
talking with headphones on so uh I
imagine it is kind of weird all right
cool
aim highs in here and suicide hey how's
it going how's the new job yeah let me
know I haven't haven't heard from you in
a while and also sometimes I call you by
whatever your name is on on YouTube but
I mean I know what your real names are a
lot of times either from github or
Twitter or something so if you have a
preference if for some reason you don't
want me to use your real name on my
stream let me know because otherwise
I'll probably end up doing it at some
point it just reminded me because I
always say aim high because that's his
name in chat but I do know his real name
from Twitter so so let me know if it
doesn't matter to you that's cool and
I'll just use whichever name and
otherwise I don't want to I don't know
if somebody's like in the witness
protection program or something I don't
want to mess things up for you so so let
me know if you don't want me to say your
name on the stream oh okay John had a
good idea the planning guide could be a
modal hmm
alright I'm gonna think about that if
the planning guy pops up as a modal then
I don't have to worry about about
anything happening to their their data
in the form I'm yeah I'm gonna think
about that I kind of like that idea
especially since I'm gonna condense the
planning guide a bit before the Planning
guide was spread out over several pages
so a modal wouldn't make quite as much
sense it would be a lot of information
for the modal but we'll see yeah that
might that might work
Hamza says the link here is is only
bolded would it be hard for the user to
distinguish between the basically to
make to know that that is a link yeah
it's possible that it could be difficult
I could maybe make it a different color
that would be more usually what I would
I have done on other sites is the links
not just bolded it's actually a
completely different color whatever the
the main accent color is that I'm using
so maybe that would be better to go with
a different color I really don't want to
put in the the underline the standard
default underlined under a link I just
don't like how that looks
to me if the underlined under the link
just looks really really old-school like
the early internet and so I don't I
don't like it although I I understand
that people would immediately see like
hey that's a link but if I if I don't if
I can get away with not having that and
people still understanding it's a link
I'd rather do it like that but I do
understand what you're saying
okay so Kevin says I think you can get
away without ejecting by just creating a
server das file and changing the NPM
start to do NPM run build and then nodes
serve Jaso okay cool that's good to know
I'd rather not eject if I don't have to
so I will I will try that I'm actually
I'm gonna copy what you just put in the
live chat and paste it somewhere because
in case the chat gets really long and
that message gets deleted I want to have
it so I'm gonna put it right in there
cash cash yep says I'm lacking
motivation to code I want to but I end
up not doing it yeah that's tough I know
I've been there I guess trying to think
what I do to get motivated it's easier
to get motivated now than before I guess
when I was freelance because now like I
have a boss that could potentially say
like what are you doing get to work so
that that helps I found when I like
motivation usually I'm getting depressed
so I need like exercise possibly
caffeine but does anyone else have any
good ideas for getting motivated you
know go ahead and put them in the live
chat if if you do okay Sebastian I
finally understand why why Sebastian put
the the frown emoji in the chat so I had
missed the first time that he said gave
the solution to to what was going on
here so sorry you know sometimes it
takes me about to see things in the chat
so the chat is is very active right now
so I'm gonna have to pull away from it
and do some coding here in a minute
because we're already a half hour in and
I've done very little
all right so let me
let me do some coding I'll do my I'll
set my timer so I'll come back to the
live chat whenever my Pomodoro timer is
up or if I need your help I'll come back
to the live chat you know before it's up
which the likelihood of me needing help
is really high as as you all know but
for now so don't worry if I didn't get
you your comment or question and the lab
chat I will get to it eventually
let's see
so actually you know what I want to try
first just to see cuz this is this is
going to be a big deal I'd like to try
this because I'm really curious as to
how I would do the custom server stuff
yeah
yeah let me see where's my package.json
file so in case you're you're not
familiar with what's going on here maybe
if you're just joining or you're not
familiar with react so we created this
using create react app and that took
care of a lot of the setup that goes
into like setting up web pack and hot
module reloading and a lot of stuff that
can be a headache to set up at the
beginning the project and you don't
really need to know how to do all that
if you just want to get started and do
something basic with react but if you
want to start doing custom things you
can't do it by default with create react
app because a lot of that stuff is kind
of hidden away and that's what makes it
so easy to get started with and use but
it also makes it difficult to customize
so they built in a feature called eject
which lets you basically see all that
customization stuff once you eject
though you can't go back so I'd rather
not eject if I don't have to if I'm not
a ejected yet I can still update and
take advantage of whatever new stuff is
coming so it's it's definitely a
trade-off I've done it I've done
projects where I never ejected and I've
also done stuff where I have ejected so
I guess it just really depends on what
you what you need to do so right now I
know that at some point I'm gonna want
to do things in my server ojs file I was
thinking that I might have to eject but
I might maybe I won't have to eject so
let's see I wonder
I just had a thought could I make a
branch in eject the branch and then just
see what what happens just see how bad
that is and then still have my master
branch be not ejected right that could
work right let's uh I kind of want to do
it now that I've talked about it yeah
let's do that actually I really want to
show you all what its if you've never
done it before seen it like so that you
don't have to try to eject one of your
own projects and you know potentially
mess it up if you don't want to so let's
do it on this because I haven't done a
project that I've ejected for a long
time so yeah let's try it and see what
happens
what do you think
but Sebastian Sebastian recommended just
make a copy of the folder the project is
in so you don't mess up your get would
that mess it up I mean could I would it
mess it up that bad that I should
completely have a different directory
for my project because otherwise I kind
of like
okay yes it seems like a few people yeah
that's what I was thinking
Kevin says that worst case you could
just delete the node modules and do an
NPM install again yeah that's what I was
thinking right I can that should work
right although now that you all said
that maybe it does make a lot of sense
that I should that I should do this in a
different directory so let me do that
where's my where's my terminal that so
if you join late and didn't see the link
here's the link let me put that I pasted
it in really early on like within the
first minute so I'm gonna paste it in
again just in case cuz you see there's
not really a lot of connections open
okay so let me go
and she's gonna go to
all right so I'm gonna pull the project
into this folder and then eject it in
there and then that way there's no
chance that I will mess up what we're
actually working on so this would be a
good demo of how to pull down projects
from get up as well so this might be a
good day for beginners a little bit
different than what I thought we were
gonna do
I just noticed today that github is like
the first thing on my screen when I open
a new tab and I was proud of that like I
go to get up more frequently than
anything else I was afraid it would be
like Netflix or something and then but
notice github so I've been working a lot
let's see maybe I not CIA Resource
Center okay so if you want to clone a
repo which I'm sure you've heard me say
that before so you go to github and then
go to the repo that you want in this
case this is what we want and we go to
this clone or download button and copy
now this depends on how you have it set
up if you have your github account set
up on your machine with SSH keys you can
use this otherwise you can use HTTPS and
I think that will prompt you to type in
your github password so otherwise with
SSH you don't need the password so but
either one will work so I've copied that
and I'm gonna now I'm in the directory
that I want to be in for this and I'm
gonna type git clone and I'm going to
put that in
now let's go Resource Center there you
go
so here's our files now once you've done
that you want to either type in NPM
install or Yarn depending on what you
want to use if you have yarn and the
file has a yarn lock then you probably
just want to use yarn but that's
entirely up to you so what you would you
like to use for that and that's going to
take all the stuff in package.json and
it's going to install that so otherwise
if you try to run this right now it may
not work because you don't have actually
there's no way it will work I'm pretty
sure you have none of the node modules
right now generally you don't want to
sync your node modules to your github
repo that's just kind of a waste since
you have your package JSON everybody
that downloads it knows what it they
need so there's no reason to track your
your node module folder okay so now
let's type in your and I should have
done this immediately so it was working
while I was talking so now we're gonna
type yourn I just realized that this is
really tiny sorry about that and you
make it bigger
okay so yarn is now getting all the
packages and dependencies that it needs
and installing them so when yarn is
finished we'll have everything we need
to run this now what we're gonna do as
soon as this finishes it's actually run
eject and then we can compare since
we'll have both versions open we can
compare the file structure just to get
an idea of what's different update yarn
I get this message a lot I think
sometimes either yarn gets updated a lot
or I'm doing it wrong
okay
[Music]
I'm gonna open this up in Adam and we
see the package.json that we have here
which is the same as the one we have on
screen so pretty much the same or
exactly the same here we go it's exactly
the same so when I run it Jack then we
can compare and see the differences so
let me go back here and I'll run is it
just eject yeah so using yarn or NPM or
whatever you want I think you can just
yarn eject I don't think you have to
yarn run eject let's see if this works
yep are you sure you want to eject its
permanent yes I'm sure
ejected successfully that was so fast
okay
so all this stuff should now be in our
our package.json so let's check it out
yep all right so now look at all this
stuff so we couldn't see a lot of this
before and now we can this was all still
there behind the scenes it was just kind
of hidden to make things a bit more
simple okay so now we we actually have
you know we have access to all of this
what else do we have we have a scripts
folder and this has some additional
files some additional JavaScript files
and we have a config folder
so we got a lot of extra stuff we have
our webpack configs which like there's a
lot of stuff I mean there's a lot of
stuff coming it out but there's there's
still a lot of stuff in there so you can
see it saves you a lot of time and
effort configuring configuring all of
this but that's what happens when you
eject so there we go
I'm now that I have ejected now I'm kind
of like thinking I definitely don't want
to eject if I don't have to because now
I remember how crazy it gets when you
eject and that all of a sudden there's
all this stuff okay
so
definitely not going to commit that that
change so for demonstration purposes we
have ejected and now I actually have a
another place where I could potentially
just switch over and test what's going
on you know see how how hard it would be
to do it with it ejected so I guess it's
beneficial to have that right now not
hopefully I won't need to use it though
and you can see why it just gets a lot
more complex when you have all that
they're just my package.json file alone
got really big so it looks like how much
time okay I'm being on time I'm not I
see a lot happening in the live chat and
I will check back on that just seen a
few of the the comments here I see
Patrick says ya know eject yeah you can
see it's crazy when you eject
it's definitely I'm I'm not I'm not at
all an expert at web pack so you know
all this kind of stuff I have not really
sure what's going on okay so now now I
think it's it's obvious to me I think I
needed to see that just to know like how
worth it is it for me to try to make
this work without ejecting and now that
I've seen all the extra stuff that
happens when you eject like I said I've
seen it before but it's been a really
long time so I had forgotten but now
that I've seen it I'm a little bit more
motivated to try to make things work
without having to eject so that was
useful at least for me hopefully it was
useful for you all to to see what what
happens when you eject that so let's
let's go in now and actually start
working with our form
okay so here's a question do I once
do I want to make these controlled
components
if I'm gonna use a UI what was that the
material UI camera what the name was
form Z that was that I think it was form
Z this one yeah form Z material you I
would this then take care of some of
that would I would I end up messing this
up if I try to or just from what I'm
seeing right here I guess not
all right so I do want to kind of test
this and read up on it so I'm not going
to run this right now so I'm gonna move
that off to the side I just don't want
to spend a lot of time reading
documentation while I'm live-streaming
because that's not probably not really
beneficial to anyone to stare at my
screen while I read something all right
so let's let's go where I lost my there
it is okay so for our controlled
components basically when it end up
doing something like this so this is the
section on handling multiple inputs
which obviously is what we're doing we
have a lot of inputs on that page so the
way that they're doing it here in the
documentation is their adding in in the
state
the name okay so they're taking the name
of the input and then they're using that
as the key and then obviously the value
of the input is the value and then on
their handle they have a handle input
change event you can see basically it's
kind of nice so they only have to say
you know set state once everything else
they just make it a Const and then
they're able to grab what they need from
that event so they can grab the value so
you can see they even have you know
check box which is great cuz we're gonna
have a lot of check boxes so that's cool
so I don't really have one I have to
make a cost for every single one so
hopefully there's a better way to do
that because that would be a lot but
that's better than having to have a
totally different you know called a set
state going on so I guess what I need to
do is give a name to these inputs
because I don't think they have names
they don't have IDs or anything so we
need to do that before we do anything
else because we have no way to identify
them so let me see I'm assuming that
material UI just passes down the same
thing yeah name okay we can just use
name like Norma
so just give it to a few of these
okay so I'm just gonna do a couple just
to make sure that this is working and
then in our props
I guess we'll have we don't really want
any of these to have a beginning value
right yeah cuz we're using our floating
label basically so we don't we don't
need a value to begin with so since
that'll be a string I guess we'll start
out with string what was the next one
email okay
subscribe this
oops let me grab this as well sure you
get that first
we get semicolons so I'm not gonna
manually get rid of the semicolons
they'll be you gotten rid of when we
commit okay so I think we have we need
the on change and other than that I
think we have everything
let me change
okay I misread this completely so I was
very mistaken a few minutes ago so let
me correct and I'm sure you've already
corrected me in a live chat so I misread
this so I apologize I was reading over
this hastily before the stream was about
to start so and I misread this somehow
thinking that I would have to make a
Const for each one which I thought
seemed a bit ridiculous and in fact it
was ridiculous because that's not even
what they were doing so it looks like I
won't have to do that so what's
happening with these cost is so this is
the target I don't know what I was
thinking now it seems so obvious to me I
guess that happens sometimes I didn't
have any caffeine until just right when
I started this dream so I'm gonna blame
it on that I've got my G fuel no so now
my brain is working
okay so we're grabbing the event okay
we're getting the target and we're
saving that to a variable now we're
using that to get the value so we can
set that if it equals checkbox right
then we're gonna get target checked
otherwise else right we're gonna get
target value okay and that's because for
for the other inputs we can just grab
the value and that'll give us the value
of the input but for checkboxes it's
different so we just there's we don't
check the value of it we just want to
know whether it's checked or not all
right and that's gonna be a boolean so
this makes a lot more sense now then we
want to get the name and that's what
we're using here so we're gonna get the
name and the
that makes so much sense sorry sorry for
being such an idiot a few minutes ago so
I'm sure those of you who know what
you're doing with with you know with
react knew immediately that I didn't
know what I was talking about but I
really apologize to those of you who are
new I probably confuse you quite a bit
I myself was confused so sorry about
that so it seems like now we actually do
have everything we'll need so let's just
try it out and see see if we're actually
gonna be able to change the state so I'm
just gonna type in some nonsense here
and then we're gonna check the state let
me inspect this and then I'll bring over
dev tools assuming it worked I'll bring
it over and be impressive if it didn't
work I'll just won't even show it but it
did work okay so let me make it bigger
okay so you can see here's the state for
a component our service request
component here's our state we have email
we have and this is our the nonsense
that I just typed in for all of them
okay but we have email name phone number
and that's exactly what need so we have
all these values and let me see if I can
let's do this in real time so you can
see a change you can see the flash of
kind of a green color under name as it
changes
so very cool so real-time you know on
change it updates state awesome now I
just realized that we in fact did not
add the value like I said we are going
to do so let me do that really quick
value equals
okay I should probably check the
documentation to make sure I did that
right but I'm pretty sure that's how it
was let's make sure that still works
okay cool
now if I want to go I wonder if it will
let me change the state right here in
dev tools it'll be really cool if it
does
there we go okay let me see if I can
change it cool all right so you say I
change state here in dev tools and then
it changed it here so we can see since I
didn't set the value on this looks like
the phone element it shouldn't change
okay see so it doesn't change so that's
what I was trying to explain at the
beginning of the stream kind of the flow
that it was gonna take was the value is
gonna be set by the state and the state
is set by what you type in here so
hopefully that demonstrated that now my
timer did go off a minute ago so I'm
gonna go back to the live chat and all
right and the it's been an hour of
stream because my Instagram live stream
just stopped because there's an hour
limit so Wow I had 11 viewers so that's
pretty good I mean not nowhere near what
we get for the for the YouTube stream
but I mean that says as I expected but
that's cool I mean I I just kind of want
to give people the opportunity to see
what I look like in case they're
interested
sometimes we sometimes that's nice
instead of just hearing someone's voice
to be able to put a face with it and I
don't know about you but it's always
really hard for me to read like what
somebody is is feeling if I can't see
their face like are they being are they
serious or they joking or happy like
it's hard to tell so if you've if you
can see their face it's kind of easier
so I'll tell you I I'm actually smiling
a lot when I do this dream so I really
like doing this so that's normally my
expression
all right so I'm scrolling up in the
live chat it looks like I can still read
the stuff at the top so that's good so I
won't miss anyone's anyone's questions
or comments
I just saw well earlier when I was
saying I won't say your name on on-air
if you don't want me to and I've
mentioned the witness protection program
role and so that escalated quickly
witness protection it did I mean I was I
was just trying to think of some reason
why someone wouldn't want me to say the
real name that's the first thing that
came to mind okay Sebastian says I need
to remove exact in the link and check
console so I guess I'm getting an error
I have dev tools up now so let's check
that out
okay I'm gonna prop exact on the a tag
this drop from the other man link okay
never remove that I will remove that
right now so don't forget
yeah honor when I was doing this I
couldn't I remembered that I had to put
exact in somewhere when I was using
reactor outer but I couldn't remember
exactly where or how to put it in and I
didn't bother looking it up and I put it
in and at work so I just left it at that
and I didn't even check the console so
thanks for that Sebastian
okay cool so Tiffany said when we were
talking about the link and making sure
that people knew that that really was a
link so this this year this planning
guide link which is this so Tiffany said
a different color different color text
triggers
hey that's the link to so okay cool
I agree thanks for the feedback okay it
looks like Rohan agrees as well maybe
use some other highlight color for the
link okay cool
oh man brah brian says yarn or NPM and
why I'm knowledge I wonder wonder if any
like a huge debate got started let me
see it doesn't look like it oh man I was
I was afraid there's gonna be this giant
debate about your honor NPM it looks
like there wasn't occasionally that's
happened about code editors somebody
mentions a code editor and then the live
chat is just filled with people talking
about their favorite editor or usually
it's not even their favorite editor it's
whatever editor they don't like and they
talk about why it's bad so I actually
like an answer to Brian's question
I like yarn but I've heard that the
newest version of NPM has some of the
features that yarn has and it's also
fast so I liked yarn because it has the
yarn lock file and because it was faster
than NPM but if that's not true anymore
an NPM actually has a similar file and
it's just as fast or faster then it
probably makes more sense to just use
NPM since you get you'd have it anyway
instead of installing yarn in addition
to that so maybe I'll I'll have to check
out the newest version of NPM and see
what I think about it and then I might
actually switch away from yarn but for
now I'm gonna stick with yarn until I
get the time to check it out check out
MTM again the newest version
okay so we had a question earlier about
you know how to stay motivated to code
when you don't feel like coding umberto
says I watch people create things or
tutorial videos about stuff I'm
interested in to get motivated so that's
that's cool
I don't even think about that it's a
good idea I guess that would be
motivating like just to remind remind
yourself of the cool things that you can
do yeah that is cool it is really
amazing like coding is about you just
get to create things like Withers
there's nothing there and you just you
start typing code and all things happen
that's really cool and then you can you
can just mess with it and start over
completely and it doesn't matter if you
break it does you it's just really cool
there's not really a lot that you could
do that's like that you could compare
that to just the flexibility of it I say
I said I listen to Johnny Cash to get
motivated oh cool Don Xavier says
motivated nothing like some nice tunes
got to work with tunes and coffee okay
cool
yo so says he should get engaged with
his peers okay yeah that's I do I agree
with the music thing and the coffee
thing as well but then also Joseph's
comment about getting engaged with peers
that can be really good I'm I I would I
guess I don't have a lot of experience
with having peers that also code because
I mostly code by myself it's and I'm not
like working with other people in
project until now that I'm working with
all of you
so that actually is motivation for me
that I know I'm gonna do the stream and
so I wanna I want to get better and know
more what I'm doing so I could be more
helpful to you all but I know like
when I I don't I don't often work out as
much as I should
nowadays but when I was younger I used
to work out all the time and if you have
a partner or some people that you work
out with you're way less likely to skip
a workout and I imagine it's probably
the same thing if you have other people
that you code with and you talk about
coding with you're way less likely to
stop coding because they will encourage
you and call you out if you don't and
you'll have like positive motivation to
want to have new things to talk about
when you see them so that's definitely a
good idea
let's see Hamza says why don't you use
template strings man they're so better
actually I'm not sure I can't remember
what I was doing when that comment came
up so Hamza I'm sorry I'm not sure what
you're referring to with the template
strings thing so normally I do use
template strings or template literal
syntax I use that almost all the time
unless it's something really simple and
then I just use sometimes I'll just use
normal like string concatenation Tiffany
says listen to upbeat music while you
work suggestion to Door Cinema Club okay
never heard that I'll have to check it
out Phillip says try the Neo method
electronic actually I I listened I
listened to a lot of different music
when I code so depending on the day I
could be listening to anything it's the
only music that I probably never listen
to is country music so don't like
country music but pretty much anything
else I like but I K I do listen to
electronic music today I listen to a lot
of lecture
music I don't know about anyone here but
if I really want to get motivated I
listen to music from the Rocky movies so
I don't if you've ever seen any of the
Rocky movies a lot of them came out I
think they started coming out in the
seventies some came out in the 80s and
then they started making new ones within
the last 10 years or so but the
soundtracks always get me fired up I
remember watching those movies when I
was a kid and getting so pumped up so
uh-huh so that that helps me maybe if
there's some something like that that
you have like strong emotions with when
you hear it that could probably help you
out
alright Isaiah says how important is it
to know graph QL for a react developer
I don't know graph QL and the take the
truth I never considered myself a react
developer but maybe I should think about
it because I'm building sites for my job
and for clients on the side with react
so I'm not really sure how you define
react developer but I develop sites with
react so maybe I am I don't I don't know
but anyway that's not really the
question honestly I do think graph QL is
really cool from what I've read about it
I do want to learn it and I think that
it's going to be used more so like if I
had to guess I would say a graph QL is
going to be the thing that people use it
seems like it makes a lot more sense I
mean I like REST API as I love working
with REST API so they're really easy to
work with but a graph QL does seem like
it makes more sense than the REST API is
just in terms of like you can get
exactly the data you want and less trips
so it seems like there would be less
waste in terms of getting data that you
really don't need and making a lot of
extra trips
whereas with graph QL you could probably
get exactly the data you need in one
trip so I think graph QL is important is
it necessary to know definitely not it's
important I don't know I think it's
pretty important I think right now you
definitely don't need to know it but I
think it's going to be more used more
more and more as you come or more people
adopt it and I don't know that's just my
my guess but I mean who knows what's
gonna happen something else better could
come out in a week and then we'll forget
about graph QL but I would I would say
if you have the time to learn it and you
want to learn it then go for it
Rowen says by the way the upload file
list is not scrollable might get people
confuse
okay cool I'm gonna move this over the
other screen just in case I have like
some top-secret files actually I just I
don't have anything crazy but I do have
files that are like the names of people
who have applied to for the web
developer job so I don't want to put
their names on YouTube so I'm gonna open
this on my other screen just in case
okay I'm cool I just have I'll bring
this back I just have my thumbnails for
all my videos here so let's open this
let me open a bunch of them and see
what's going on here
okay so you're saying it's not
scrollable for this list okay
yeah people might get confused I'm not I
don't really know offhand how I would
make this scrollable
onna maybe I could do something with CSS
with the overflow yeah maybe I could do
something with the overflow property so
I will add that to the list
and I'm gonna give that a one Pomodoro
cycle because in case my first idea
doesn't work it might take a little bit
longer
alright cool thanks for that Rohan I'm
actually really glad I finally like kind
of set this up because it is a lot
easier for me to just put something in
here instead of forgetting about it
okay let me see man I just look there's
a lot of stuff going on the live chat I
want to make sure I get to all of it but
probably be a good idea to do a bit more
with this
let me think what I need
actually you know what I'm kind of
thinking there's not really anything
that everything that I'm gonna do at
this point for a while is just gonna be
repetition so I'm just gonna be doing
the same thing that I did with this to
all of these and then at that point I
would maybe start working on something
else related to this so I think I'm kind
of at the point where by the time I
would get all this done I would want to
end the stream anyway so instead of just
repeating the exact same thing that I
did which I don't think would be very
helpful I think I'm gonna take the
questions us simply because the there's
so much in the live chat I'm only
halfway through everything that was in
there so I definitely want to get to the
questions also I might I do kind of want
to get out of work at a decent time
because I think I need to go to the
doctor's so I actually I hurt my wrist
so I don't know you might have noticed
if you watched on the Instagram feed
that I was holding my wrist so told my
right hand and I'm right-handed and
maybe like a month ago I was like
playing with my kids in the pool when I
was throwing them and at some point like
after I've been throwing them for a
really long time and I was tired I
lifted one of them up and I just felt
something like it's pain in my wrist and
I just tried to be tough and say like oh
that's no big deal
it'll be fine and I never did anything
about it and it slowly gotten worse and
worse every day to the point now where
if I use my wrist at all it hurts and
that's a problem because obviously like
I I need to move my wrist around like
even moving my wrist around to select
things you know like on the screen you
know to move the cursor around hurts so
I think I probably ought to go to the
doctor's just on the off chance that
maybe something serious
at least maybe should get like some sort
of brace or something so that I can not
move it as much because right now it's
just really hard not to move it like I
always some like picking up the baby
you're doing something and I just keep
making it worse anyway enough about that
I'm sure no one watches this for my
health updates
let's see but I guess it is it is a good
lesson if you're a developer you need
your hands most likely to work so take
care of them and don't put off getting
them checked out if you've heard
something alright so at this point if
you are here for the code and you don't
want to stick around for the question
and answer session thank you so much for
watching and you can you can safely tune
out probably won't be doing any more
coding and I'll be back tomorrow most
likely at the same time otherwise if you
can stick around for a little bit longer
and have a question or want to help out
and answering some questions then check
out the live chat put your question in
there if you're shy you can just direct
message me on Twitter and I'll try to
get you a question whenever I can or if
you can't stick around to hear my answer
you can either catch the answer later on
if you watch the recording of this or
you can message me some other way on
Twitter or some other social media the
link for my Twitter is in the
description okay I hadn't said that in a
while so I figured I may as well say it
for anyone that's new and doesn't know
how the stream kind of works so
unofficially the stream is split up into
two parts the code part and the question
and answer part all right so we're still
talking about in in regard to the
motivation thing so well Mary says I
have have a few things that help with
motivate
group co-working not so much teamwork
but working around other people working
so sharing that working energy oh that's
cool
yeah I could I can see that so maybe
actually I have rarely done this but I
see a lot of people especially like
coders on Instagram always for posting
pictures of them working at a cafe or
something with other people so I don't
do that a lot just because where I'm at
there's not really a lot of cafes with
good Wi-Fi that you could go and work at
this it's not not an option for me but I
think that's kind of at least it seems
popular from from what I see online so
good advice thank you
Yosef says by the way I'm learning Ajax
and listen to your live coding in the
background to help me to get motivated
oh cool all right so I guess my live
coding can be motivation as well I could
definitely see my live coding being
motivation for somebody saying like how
how does this guy have a live stream on
YouTube that people watch and like I'm
better than him how does this okay I
could see people being motivated by that
but anyway I appreciate that appreciate
you saying that
well Patrick says the brain food Spotify
playlist off to check that out I don't
know if I've listened to the brain food
playlist maybe I have at some point yeah
definitely if you um if you like
listening to music and you can spare the
I don't know like ten dollars or less a
month to get Spotify Premium I
definitely recommend that and I this is
not sponsored by Spotify this is my
honest opinion my productivity went up
when I got Spotify Premium because the
commercials got so annoying for me it
broke my train of thought
and it really did help to get spotify
premium so i think that's a legitimate
business expense so if you don't have it
try it out sometimes they have really
good deals where you can get like three
months for 99 cents a month or something
like that so try it out whenever one of
those deals happen that that really
helped me out
Rohan says working with a couple of
people who are motivated enough can be a
push for everyone but teams generally
take motivation away okay that's
interesting so yeah I can agree with
that I guess it depends on who you're
working with on your team I would say
there there are some people and some
personalities that are just a drain on
the team but then sometimes there are
people that are just so positive that it
it does help I know there there used to
be someone that worked in my department
and she retired but even now when I see
her every time I see her she tells me oh
Jessie you're so smart you can do
anything you're going places and she
always says that I always laugh you know
but that makes me feel so good about
myself and she's she's not I mean she I
think genuinely believes that and she
would convince me like once I applied
for a job that was way out of my league
and it was partly because she convinced
me and talked me up that I that I should
do it that I would be great at it so
people like that can help you be
motivated really positive upbeat people
I think are great for motivating you so
if you have people like that in your
life hang out around them more often or
try to find somebody like that and make
them your friend
okay it looks like okay cool so Kevin is
giving me some some links I'm gonna copy
these and check these out after the
stream okay all right I see this one
definitely looks helpful is exactly what
we want to do using create react app
with react router and Express j/s this
this is exactly what we're doing okay
cool so thank you thank you Kevin
definitely gonna check that out
yeah Rowan says node modules isn't
traced by get yeah actually so by it by
default node modules can be traced but I
get so you you do have to put it in your
git ignore file so let me let me show
you this actually because I do see this
occasionally the people will have their
node modules in their repo so it's
really easy fix here within your get
ignore file if you don't have this in
your project like you can just copy it
from somebody else's project that's
similar to yours if you need to I never
make these from scratch I always copy it
from either a previous project of mine
or a similar project I have someone
else's and you want to say don't track
node modules and then you know there's
other stuff in here this one was created
automatically when I did create react
app but if you were doing the project
from scratch then this wouldn't be there
automatically so you would have to put
it in if you happen to do your project
and setup get and forget to do this
first and then you want to ignore your
files later on you got you have to run a
few commands to get that to work so let
me I actually just did this some someone
wanted me to take a look at their
project and so I I cloned it and the
node modules were being tracked so
I sent a pool request basically just
uploading a GUID ignore I think I
changed a few other things but one of
the things I changed for them was I put
this in so let me let me just show you
how to do that quickly I guess I'm not
well I'm not going to be able to show
you because obviously I have it I have
it set up the right way but let me show
you where I guess I can at least give
you the resource that I use because it's
happened in the several times so it
would be useful let's see
I'm trying to tape on my other screen to
show you this resource but I can't type
today
so all right there we go so what you
want to do is get you want to do a git
RM cache and then you can put the name
of your file if it's just one file or
like let's say you just you didn't have
this at all and there's a bunch of stuff
and now you upload your get ignore file
or you create your get ignore file then
you can just do like alright you want to
do the die you want to do everything and
then you can go ahead with adding your
your other files so you can do a git
status it'll show you everything and
then you want to add and then push the
changes so I'm pretty sure that's how
I've done it before I just I was looking
for that command so that's what you want
to do to get everything back back in
order and let me know I'm sure you'll
let me know in the live chat if I've
missed something here and someone has
noticed that I'm missing something
important but there's like there's a ton
of Stack Overflow questions about that
so I'm sure you'll you'll be able to
find something you know if you need a
little bit more instruction on that ok
Dixie says I find watching Jesse's live
streams give me gets me motivated seeing
him go through the errors and everything
is comforting to me at least a hug good
food food and music can help too yeah I
like that comment I've had a few times
I've had people say like that they they
like that I make mistakes and work
through them and I really I like that
comment because that was really my one
of like the the main points of this was
to show people that I make mistakes and
because a lot of your tutorial
videos like they edit out any mistakes
right you know you want to keep the
videos as short as possible and to the
point so you edit out the mistakes so I
wanted people to see the mistakes so you
know they don't get the impression that
if they're making mistakes somehow
there's something wrong with them when
in reality we all make mistakes all the
time but it's always funny when I get
that because I know people mean it as a
compliment but in the back of my mind
I'm thinking like like everybody likes
just watching me mess up and I know
that's not how you how you all mean it
but it's just funny to me that in in a
sense that's true right like the main
draw of this live stream is the fact
that I mess up and try to work through
it so I don't know maybe it's just me
but I think that's kind of that's kind
of funny it's amusing but anyway
Dixie thanks for saying that I'm glad
that that that's comforting to you
that's that that's definitely what I
what I intend is you know for people to
feel a little bit better when they make
a mistake because they see me make so
many
John Hanson said you're gonna need some
heavy metal music before going before
you hit that Enter key to eject so yeah
if I would have seen that I could have
switched to some some heavy metal but I
think I didn't see it in time so
actually my Spotify stopped I made it
through this big playlist and so just
stops I just restarted it again Patrick
says what is the point of using it if
you can't feel confident that you can
branch an experiment just use a branch
you can always clone from github yeah
that's what I thought that's what I
thought too at first Patrick it was
actually kind of cool the way I did it
in another folder and then it was easier
to compare them side-by-side I know I
could have just switched back and forth
from the branches but I'm I'm actually
like a little bit interested in going in
now to that where the the other
directory where I each acted and just
messing with things and possibly
breaking it but I don't know to me now I
like inadvertently have a little
playground now that I can mess with all
the configurations so I'm kind of I'm
thinking if I get a little bit of time I
can go mess around and maybe learn
webpack a bit a bit better so anyway it
turned out alright I definitely agree
like I I had figured I could just make a
branch and then I was kind of
second-guessing myself there and just
went with the entirely safe route but
for future reference for anybody it
should have been fine to just make a
branch and do do the eject on the branch
and I could have just switched back and
or Kalandar
so so I do I do great Patrick and Kevin
looks like Kevin was agreeing with
Patrick as well aha I mentioned earlier
that when I open up a new tab its
it's github its first and I said that I
was I was proud of that I was afraid it
would be Netflix rhoann says his Netflix
I don't mean anything bad by that if
you're if you tab who's Netflix that's I
like Netflix to although my Netflix
isn't hasn't been working I suspect that
my wife canceled the Netflix account and
didn't tell me I keep forgetting that to
ask her about it but every time I try to
watch Netflix for the last like few days
it hasn't worked but anyway don't feel
bad if yours is his Netflix on the
merits this is my work computer by the
way so maybe that would that would make
a difference I never watch Netflix on
this computer
haha bill said is his local host haha
that's awesome that's that's a that's
really cool
oh that's right okay so I see Kevin says
you don't need a password not even a
github account to clone just to push
that's right thanks Kevin thank you for
clarifying that anyway I don't know what
I was thinking but when I went in when I
when I showed you all how to clone from
github I mistakenly said that if he went
with the HTTPS you would have to put in
your password but that was wrong you
only need your password if you were to
then try to push to a repo that you've
cloned with the HTTPS so don't worry
about you can clone and as as Kevin said
in the live chat you don't even need to
have a github account to clone using the
HTTP link so forget what I said earlier
that was a mistake
hopefully hopefully I didn't mislead
anyone there but yet only if you're
going to push does the password come
into play so sorry about that
okay so aim high says have you finished
your react nano degree course so that
was asked a while ago so not sure if
you're still around to get the answer
but I haven't finished it yet so the way
it the way it works is the courses
don't start so like I started the first
part I just wanna show you how this
works
basically the courses are split up and
they have start dates so I finished the
first part so the curriculum here I
finished react the introduction and
react fundamentals but the next section
react and redux starts in six days 21
hours 22 minutes and 14 seconds so I
can't take it now so I have been doing
some of the extracurricular stuff so I
started like the ex6 es6
things so these are just like you don't
need to do these to complete the course
but they're just in addition which i
think is cool so they have stuff on here
6 asynchronous JavaScript getting github
and then career feedback stuff so like
helping you with your resume you get up
profile LinkedIn so I'm gonna work on
these when I have time until the next
one gets up and running so this one is
starts in six days and then the last one
react native doesn't start to 441 days
so I will not be through with this
course anytime soon but anyway that's
how it works so I was I was a little bit
surprised cuz the other some of the
other courses don't work like this this
was this is different so not everything
on Udacity works like this
all right so me media mij a not sure how
to pronounce that so I'm gonna say media
but I'm pretty sure that's not right so
let me know how you would like me to
pronounce that but anyway the question
is what is enjoy what is the enjoyable
part of doing react app don don xavier
says simplicity and decoupling for me at
least and youth so yeah I guess I mean
what am I like right I don't know I kind
of like react there's some features of
react that we're really useful to me
so like server-side rendering so being
able to do server-side rendering which
is not a new thing right like you can
server-side render and other link like
PHP you know like but being able to
service that render and then use the all
the same stuff to do client-side
client-side routing that's really cool
and useful I like that I kind of I I
thought it was weird at first to mix in
JavaScript and HTML and CSS but now I
think it's kind of cool to do it all in
one place and have it all like all
together for each component so that's
that's really cool if I probably if I
thought about it more I would think of
some other things but just off the top
of my head that's that's kind of what I
like what's what's enjoyable for me
about it and acts honestly this might
sound bad but if I'm being totally
honest react is just like the cool thing
to do right now I mean this is not a
good reason to choose something so I
think react is good in itself but it is
a little bit cool to be like doing the
using the thing that everybody is
talking about on Twitter and stuff right
like I'm not saying that that's a good
reason but I'm just saying that that's
that's a bonus right whenever you know
ever I can honestly say that like I'm
using technology that's being used by
some of the big tech companies and some
of the latest like coolest things that
are coming out I like being able to say
that right that's that's nice that I
don't I never like saying like yeah I'm
building stuff with technology that's
outdated right that's not I would never
want to say that hey I would never say
that with pride right but it's it's kind
of cool to say like hey react is a
somewhat new technology that is being
adopted by a lot of like cutting-edge
companies and I'm using that so that's
really that's kind of cool too like I
said not not the reason you'd never want
to pick something just because you think
it's cool or you know popular at the
moment but it's a bonus if the thing
that you like for other you know reasons
also is cool okay me just said this
looks like suffering but I support
efforts yeah I guess it may look like
suffering it sometimes but sometimes
like stuff works and it works out well
and it's really cool so yes it just
depends depends on what you're doing
all right don't Savior so seeing this
for the first time it looks like a
rollercoaster ride but once you delve
into it it's simple yeah yeah I mean it
does it gets a lot easier bill says I
had to come back to react about three
times before I finally click now it's my
go-to when doing any project to the
point where if I sit down to write plain
old HTML I stall for a minute yeah
definitely
Don Xavier says seen here me just says I
hope it becomes funnier at some point -
more fun yeah yeah definitely react took
me a while to get used to as well so I
think things don't start to get fun
until you really get the hang of it III
think a lot of things are like that not
just with programming so it's probably
not gonna seem that fun at first but
once you're comfortable with it it does
get more fun like I I've found it to be
more fun like I went back and redid one
of my projects for free code camp and
react that I had originally done with
jQuery and I thought it was just it was
more fun to make with react the second
time around than it was with jQuery so I
mean little comparisons like that
definitely make me realize that I enjoy
using react but I didn't always it was
really frustrating at first Sebastian
says arrow function and no need to bind
okay cool let me so I remember exactly
what I was doing at that point so let me
show you just so we all know what we're
talking about so I copied this from the
documentation the react documentation
basically I just copied it because I was
I was thinking well I'm gonna copy
everything over so I make sure this
works but when I was copying it I kind
of thought there's got to be a better
way to do this and
in fact there is if you use arrow
functions then you don't have to do this
because that that takes care of it so
you definitely need to change this up
but just just know that this line here
is definitely not necessary
let's see Don Xavier says when you start
using es6 and Redux with it it's a whole
lot of fun yeah for sure when you get to
hanging up some of the stuff in es6 it
is fun like I mean this is kind of
simple but like template literals
template literals changed my life
alright so and me it made things so much
more simple
you know I at one point I was doing it
seemed like everything I was doing
required me to make these long like
strings concatenate all these things
together and then template literals you
know like I learned about him and it was
just like wow is this just save me so
much time
and then like you've been able to use
let and const like it took me a while to
get the hang of when I should use let
and Const and what they are good for but
now like it makes a lot of sense and
that's not it's not there's a lot of
other things in es6 that come in handy
like like arrow functions right I don't
know react would be so much harder
without arrow functions so anyway that's
that's cool I haven't done a lot with
Redux yet but I've seen some things at
like some presentations at conferences
and on YouTube about Redux and it looks
really cool so I'm looking forward to
learning more about it da bill says I
only have a few packets of G fuel left
need to order a tub of powder soon yeah
definitely so I as you probably heard me
say before I drink g fuel for my
caffeine often when I'm streaming and
Bill chatted out as well so that's
pretty cool I need to see if I get like
some sort of an affiliate code or
something so like I can give it out to
you guys and you can get like a certain
percent off and then I get some money or
something or at least some free G fuel I
should do that actually I had an idea
this morning the
I should try to get like all of my
referral codes and things that I have
from various things and then just put
them on a website somewhere so that you
all can get discounts like you know I
have those codes sometimes where it's
like if someone uses your discount code
they get like $10 off or like $10 and
credit and you do - it would be cool to
like have that and then that way if you
are gonna use something anyway you might
be able to get a discount and then as a
bonus I might get something out of it -
that might be cool and then you guys
could see what products I use I guess I
mean especially with with tech stuff you
might be interested in that so maybe
I'll do that at some point not really
high on my priority list right now but
that might be a cool thing it might save
you also money and if I were to do that
it would have just been it would be me
officially free code camp would not be
endorsing any of the stuff that I put on
there so I don't want to imply that at
all let's see Kevin says by the way the
syntax for name inside the object
literal is a new thing from es6 it's
called computed property names
all right cool yeah actually thanks for
pointing that out so I totally skipped
over that and just didn't say anything
but this is really cool so if you let me
let me go to in the documentation they
have so they explain this so here we go
so that part is es6 computed property
name so if you want to learn more about
it check out you know this page and the
react documentation the page on forms
but in es5 you have to write all of this
right so you'd have to have a variable
for partial state which would be an
object and then partial state name would
be given the value and then this set
state partial state right so a lot of
stuff can be boiled down to just this
really cool
and thanks for for bringing it up I feel
like you all are like catching so many
things that I'm either like saying wrong
or didn't explain so thank you you guys
are helping you you all are helping this
stream be so much better especially
today
[Music]
Rud Rud rang shoe not sure about the
name sorry if I'm messing it up says
anyone know any good tutorials for Redux
I always get lost when I see Redux I
don't really know like I said I don't
really know Redux that well so I can't
help you I think the learn code Academy
YouTube channel has some videos on redux
I like vaguely remember watching them a
while ago they're pretty old so I'm not
sure how much if Redux has changed a lot
but I think some of the basic ideas
behind it are still the same so they
might be helpful as an introduction
other than that I'm about to take the
Udacity course on Redux so I'll be able
to let you know if it's good in about a
month or so Goggin asks just being
curious if you tried Gatsby Jas I have
not tried Gatsby yet but I've had some
some people recommend it to me so I'd
like to try at some point but haven't
tried it yet bill says the docs for
Redux have some good examples beyond
that udemy and Udacity are great
resources okay cool
okay wearing shoe is asking for if
there's free ones you get me paid yeah
so
yeah definitely infinitely free ones
well I mean the YouTube thing that I was
talking about would obviously not be
paid the Udacity is definitely paid
udemy as well
bill says free code camp has some
lessons - in beta or alpha right now
can't recall yeah you could check out
the beta free code camp curriculum and
see what they have there it might be
worth it you just skip ahead and do a
couple of the the lessons in the beta
curriculum the Philip says you are away
nerdier than I thought
what did I I don't know when was that
that was like an hour ago he said that
so I don't remember what I was talking
about when I he said I was in their year
so they let me know what I was talking
about cuz I can't I don't disagree that
I'm a nerdy person but I was just
wondering what I said that was nerdy ok
so west boss has a free Redux tutorial
so Sarah Sarah says West's boss says
free Redux tutorial awesome thank you
for that
egghead dot io / redux free tutorials as
well cool I got some good resources here
Scott Co has a resource this from from
dawn Xavier and the great code adventure
has one as well
okay Joseph before I was using exact
wrong with my link and Joseph says exact
is used in nav like and route okay cool
thanks for clarifying that for me Omar
says fan from Egypt Jesse is this
project has this project have a back-end
part not right now it may end up having
some somewhat of a back-end I haven't
sided for sure yet I was actually
checked I mean you can if you can read
my tabs I was checking out MongoDB and
CouchDB just to see if I wanted to try
those out for this project it's not
necessary but we are going to be
collecting data and file uploads so I
had considered maybe having some sort of
a database to keep track of all that but
it's not 100% necessary currently I'm
keeping track of that by and in the live
version of this that we're remaking the
data gets sent out in emails it goes to
a Google sheet and it goes to our
project management system and that's all
you know through api's but it's all done
client-side which i don't want to do
anymore so potentially I don't need
another database since the data is
already being stored but it does make me
a bit nervous that I'm relying on like
all this client-side API calls I'm just
not a hundred percent like sure that
that's the most reliable way to do
things and I have had some instances
where the the file uploads didn't go
through so I know somebody try to upload
a file because I got the file name but
the actual file never went through so
that worries me that it's like there's
something slipping through the cracks
and I don't know what the issue is yeah
so anyway I'm thinking about it but I'm
just not sure not sure exactly what I
want to do about it I say it says do you
think Linux or Mac is a better
development environment for a web
developer I I don't think I can answer
that correctly because I so far I've
only used Linux on servers
I would like to use Linux I think my
next laptop is probably gonna be Linux
I'd really like to try it out I'm right
now I develop almost yeah pretty much
entirely on Mac I don't even remember
the last time I used a PC to
develop anything with but I I really
like the experience that I have on a Mac
for developing though like I said I I
don't have anything to compare it to in
terms of Linux all right Blake says or
Windows versus Mac yeah honestly I I
will have to say I've had a better
experience developing on a Mac than I
have on Windows and I developed
exclusively on Windows for years before
I switched to Mac and I didn't have a
problem with it the only reason I
switched is because the department I
work in has all Macs so I thought ok
I'll just use a Mac and instead of being
the odd one out so I used the Mac and
once after I got used to it I really
really liked it I liked it enough that I
ended up buying a macbook for myself
because i've been using an imac at work
so yeah I I prefer a Mac if we're
talking Mac versus Windows I prefer Mac
for development obviously though if
we're talking about gaming I definitely
go with Windows if if we're gonna do
some gaming stuff but yeah so that's my
opinion
I know there's strong opinions either
way on on that subject of operating
system
okay Patrick says did you use I'm trying
to see like the empty quotes rather than
and bsp for a reason I'm not sure where
that was at I'm not okay I'm thinking
I'm guessing you're talking about this
here this gets added in automatically so
I keep seeing these I'm assuming this is
something that happens is when prettier
runs on one commit so I I there's no
reason why I'm putting these in cuz I'm
not doing it it just is put in
automatically so I'm not I'm not even
sure why it doesn't really mess anything
up that I've seen but I'm guessing
that's what you were referring to
brian says but yarn has neat icons when
you run it until n PM has icons I'll
stick with yarn and then a little
winking emoji that's a that's legit
reason that's the most compelling reason
I've heard so far to use yarn I think so
I'll go with that does it seem to me
like yarn and NPM are so similar in what
they do that I just I don't think it
matters that much which one you use it's
so I mean that the debate is good you
know to try to figure out which one is
the better thing to use but I don't
think it really has impacted my
development experience that much to use
either yarn or NPM
okay Rohan says you usually require
extra tinkering to set up dev
environment on Windows actually I I do
that was true for me I don't know if
it's different cuz I'm I set everything
up on Windows 7 so maybe things are
easier now I don't really know but at
least on Windows 7 it's it did seem like
it was more difficult to get everything
running in terms of my dev environment
but I will say that I was much less
experienced when I did that so when I
was setting everything up on a Mac I had
already worked through everything on
Windows twice before because I think I
had my hard drive crash and I had to get
a new one so I did it I didn't set it up
twice so who knows maybe it was my
inexperience that made it seem like it
was more difficult but it definitely did
seem like it just didn't run quite as
smoothly Patrick says graph QL is the
future yeah I agree
Don Xavier says graph QL this is when we
were I was talking a little while ago
about someone had asked a question about
whether or not they should learn graph
graph QL if they were going to be a
reactive so in regard to that
Don Xavier says graph QL unless the
client or boss asked for it otherwise
simple REST API calls do the trick and
more even if it becomes if until it
becomes a standard when can I reuse rust
api's ok not sure the end of that I was
a little confused with but basically I
think I get what you're saying is like
REST API calls are fine now
if graph QL does become a standard then
you can always replace that though I
kind of think that was it which I think
that makes sense basically like I think
at this point it's still safe to hold
off on learning graph QL if you really
aren't sure about it yet
there's definitely be time to pick it up
if in fact graph QL does really become
the thing that replaces REST API
Giordano says hey Jessie I have a
question when the beta site will come
online I'm assuming you're talking about
the free code camp beta curriculum
correct me if I'm wrong the answer I
think officially is soon so check out I
think Quincy has had like a forum post
or blog post or something about it
recently so but I think honestly it's
like it's gonna come out when it's ready
and we're not really sure when it will
be ready I'm not actually working on it
so I don't have you know any like inside
knowledge about it or anything like that
so officially I think there is no
release date so I think they just don't
want to release it until it's ready bill
says I don't like right left scroll
because I tend to accidentally swipe
back and forth back and forward a page
from a Mac yeah I do that patrick said
refactor those into a map over the data
like name phone email dot map okay cool
off to see
I have to check that out later on I'm
gonna try wow the shames been going on
for over two hours now so let me I'm
gonna skip and just go to the questions
in the live chat and just try to answer
some of the questions especially if
there's some from some new people
[Music]
okay Rohan asks how many people actually
drop out after your end of coding
announcement actually not a lot
we're like it like 37 viewers now I
think I think we'd better closer to 50
teachers I didn't really pay attention
this time the most we had in the stream
was 60 at one time just for today's
stream and so now we're you know we're
down to 37 so I usually don't drop too
many I would say like never more than
like 25% of people drop out
okay cool Patrick says you can set up a
global get ignore so you don't
accidentally add node modules okay
that's that's really really good advice
I need to do that you know what I knew
that at some point and then totally
forgot about it that's a great idea so
I'm not the strees been going on a long
time so I'm not going to try to
demonstrate this or anything but you can
set it up globally so that for any
project you're doing it'll automatically
ignore node modules so definitely
recommend doing that because I can't
think of any reason off the top of my
head why you would want to include your
node modules in your git repo
John Hanson says is it best there he
asks is it best to have your project all
set up to go before building anything
before using it I don't know I sometimes
I start building out my project before I
start using it because there's a lot of
basic stuff that I don't really like I
know how it's gonna go I don't really
need to use get other times I start
getting immediately before I do anything
I'm not really sure what the best thing
would be to do I suppose like if you
were working on a team right off the bat
then get get up and running but
otherwise if it's just you then I don't
really see a problem in holding off if
you're just going to do some basic setup
so not sure I'm you know other people
might have some different insight into
that into that issue but that's I mean
that's what I do okay almost to the
bottom of the live chat
John Henson says I've got Jesse to blame
for getting me started thinking react
though I went the react.js route instead
of create react app yeah it it's harder
it's definitely harder to try to do
react from scratch and setup webpack and
everything I tried to do that at first
as well and and failed so sometimes it's
better just to use create react app or
next or something like that just to get
kind of get started and get comfortable
with it and then this learn the other
stuff later on if you need to Dixie says
with all the mistakes I make it's
comforting to see you and be like hey if
Jesse can get through it so can i thanks
once again I'm very glad to be be
comforting to you Jack Bennett asks
what's a good language to learn first
I'm just starting out it really depends
on what you want to do if you want to
get into web development then I
definitely recommend JavaScript I really
I can't really see any reason why or any
good argument why a web developer would
not want to learn JavaScript because you
definitely need it if you're not so much
interested in web development then you
can pick it you know depending on what
you want to do you can pick different
things so if if you want to make I Oh s
apps
I think Swift is what they develop that
in for Android is Java and now Kotlin if
you just want to learn and you're not
don't really sure what you want to do
Python seems to be a pretty easy one for
beginners
[Music]
yeah I think those are the ones people
usually talk about for beginners I mean
there's some other ones I know that get
used in like beginning computer science
courses but I don't know like like
Harvard's computer science intro course
uses I think it starts with C so not not
really sure like if you're trying to
teach yourself I'm not sure that's the
best place to start
bill says in regard to that you can take
the concepts to any language so oh I'm
sorry I was reading a second comment he
said JavaScript with web development all
right cool
definitely agree with that but you can
take the concepts to any language it's
just syntax yeah that is true like if
you learn one language that the concepts
the core concepts can translate well
into other languages so it would be
easier to pick up another computer
language like a programming language
once you learn the first one so don't
worry too much about what you're going
to start out with isaiah's asks what are
some good ideas for personal projects in
reacts react and redux
I don't know if you check out free code
camp in some of their challenges I think
those are good ideas like it if you're
trying to find like a really unique idea
to build something that nobody's built
I'm not really sure I would say like ask
ask friends and family and maybe they'll
have some idea otherwise if you're just
looking for ideas in general then check
out the free code can't challenges and
there's a lot of ideas for what to build
with user stories and things that will
give you some direction assuming you
haven't done them already
also there's great ok cool so in the
live chat there's some some links to
some medium article about things you can
build ok cool so yeah there are places
on the internet that have lists of just
ideas for things to build so check that
out it looks like the free code can't
medium publication has has a post on
that so kind of browse browse that and
see
Blake asks what framework should I use
for html5 mobile apps and then Bill says
have you thought of trying react native
that would be my recommendation as well
try out react native have I have not
used it yet so I can't say for sure but
I've I've heard a lot of good things
about it
alright I'm just scrolling through the
last little bit here trying to see if
there's any more questions and I am
reading the comments too so if you've
come in and I haven't missed that but
I'm just kind of I'm not gonna read it
out loud just because the video has been
really long at this point
okay cool I got through everything all
right bill says he's gotta run see you
later bill all right so I think I've
gotten through all the questions really
sorry if I missed something
asked me again sometime and I'll do my
best to answer thank you so much for for
watching and for being in the live chat
and contributing and for helping me out
a lot thanks to Kevin and Sebastian for
the pool requests they were awesome and
I'll be back tomorrow
so until then have a great day